what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have our first look at Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine in a new suit in the
New Classic yellow suit that Hugh
Jackman is going to be officially
wearing when he makes his return as
Wolverine in the MCU and I gotta say
this looks perfect Deadpool also has a
new suit which of course we'll talk
about as well and we'll talk about what
this scene might be right here that
they're filming but right away looking
at this suit let us know what you think
about it in the comments down below is
this what you had hoped for or do you
maybe not like it let us know put your
thoughts in the comments we've gotten a
lot of news about Deadpool 3 that we'll
go over in this video including details
about the plot and it looks like even
though Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
said that they're not going to kind of
undo the events that happened in Logan
it looks like that might actually happen
to some extent so we'll break all of
this down in this video and if you want
to stay up to date on Deadpool 3 and the
MCU be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
if you want to enter our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items be sure to subscribe and leave a
comment down below that's how you enter
we pick a winner at the end of each
month and the winner gets to pick one
item now this wolverine look is very
different than anything that we've seen
before and although it's been over 20
years Wolverine is finally getting what
he wanted yellow spandex
to actually go outside in these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
now this is a very classic suit and
what's interesting about this is that it
is very in line with his signature look
from the comics there is of course
slight variations to it but of course
there are variations to his costumes in
the comics as well it actually looks
like pretty much exactly what we're
going to be getting from Wolverine in
the X-Men 97 animated series that is
about to hit Disney plus so perhaps
Marvel Studios is trying to kind of
align it with what's happening here but
more along the lines this is probably
fan service this is the classic
wolverine look the one that we've been
wanting to see for a pretty long time
and what a great opportunity it is in
Deadpool 3 to have Wolverine in this
classic yellow suit especially when
Deadpool can make fun of him plus not to
mention one thing that we've heard about
the plot of Deadpool 3 is is that
Deadpool is going to be going through
different points in time in all of these
different universes kind of undoing
things that have happened in the
original Fox X-Men Universe of course
he's going to be creating Branch
timelines when he does this and
affecting the Multiverse extra extremely
and perhaps that is how we get Wolverine
finally in this classic yellow suit now
like I mentioned Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman did say that they're not going
to undo the events that have happened in
Logan and that may be true to a certain
extent as in they might not go to that
universe and undo anything however prior
to that way before the events of Logan
take place they could change some events
that happen and this will create a
branch timeline where Wolverine will be
very different now keep in mind this
will be a branched timeline a new
timeline so it won't necessarily undo
everything that took place in Logan but
it will create an alternate path one
that doesn't lead to the events of Logan
happening but one that perhaps leads to
the events of Deadpool teaming up with
Wolverine in a multiversal journey and
we know that Hugh Jackman has already
teased that he is going to be playing
what he calls a dual role with Wolverine
and since this is a multiversal film
many people have interpreted that as him
saying that he is going to be playing
more than one variant of Wolverine which
does make sense now we've also heard
that there are going to be cameos Galore
in this in fact it is confirmed that
Jennifer Garner is going to be returning
as Elektra in Deadpool 3. also Ben
Affleck was spotted on the set of
Deadpool 3 as well so many assume that
he is going to be returning as Daredevil
who also played alongside of Elektra in
the Daredevil film it's also been
rumored that the Fantastic Four going to
be returning with Jessica Alba and Chris
Evans playing the Human Torch which is
going to be super cool to see if that
does officially happen and we've heard
more rumors state that Deadpool is going
to be going to a universe where the
X-Men actually ruled the entire universe
under the ring of Magneto however
Professor X on the other good X-Men not
the Brotherhood but the good mutants are
also aligned with Magneto in this
universe and a part of this rumor is
that in this universe the X-Men actually
took on the Avengers and Magneto might
even wheeled mjolnir Thor's hammer so
needless to say in Deadpool 3 it does
look like there is going to be a lot of
fan service done but it's going to be
done hopefully in a really great way and
of course one thing that we have
officially seen now is the classic
Wolverine yellow suit now notice that he
isn't really wearing the blue part
around his groin area in fact his suit
looks like it's kind of matching
Deadpool suit with just a little bit of
twist to it so perhaps Deadpool actually
makes the suit for him states that well
if you're gonna be with me you're gonna
need a superhero suit and gives him that
classic Wolverine suit from the comics
the one that was mentioned in the first
X-Men movie and when he gives him the
suit perhaps he's going to break the
fourth wall because of course this is
Deadpool he always breaks the fourth
wall in his films in the comics as well
and you know he's gonna have a comment
or two or many to say about this yellow
suit and I really wouldn't be surprised
if Deadpool made him this suit made it
for him as a superhero suit but also of
course as a joke so we can make fun of
them the entire time however we're not
laughing because it actually does look
really really awesome now one thing that
is not in this photo is the headpiece we
don't have the Wolverine headpiece yet
although I'm sure he'll donate in this
movie I think it all depends on what
timelines they go down because if you
recall in 2013's The Wolverine they had
a post-credits scene where Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine did receive that
classic yellow suit
interesting now nothing really ever came
from this it was pretty much just a
tease that never came to fruition but we
can thank Ryan Reynolds for finally
bringing it to fruition now Deadpool
also has a little bit of a new suit as
well it's not too different than his
original suits that we've seen in the
other films and there's been a lot of
speculation as to why he could possibly
have a new suit but we're gonna credit
this to it's simply a new film and he's
upgraded his suit now of course there is
a chance that he could be going through
different universes and could have
possibly had his suit altered because of
that or had picked up a new suit
somewhere along the way but I don't
really think that there's any
significant changes to a suit that
actually means something major I think
he probably just upgraded the suit at
some point in time now there is rumors
that Deadpool is going to encounter
other Deadpools Deadpool variants in
Deadpool 3 including Lady Deadpool Wanda
Wilson and I gotta say I am here for
this I really would love for Deadpool to
interact with Lady Deadpool I think it
would be hilarious so there is just a
ton happening in in this movie and we
trust Ryan Reynolds to pull it off in a
really great way you know he will you
know he's taken so many years to write
this script and now it's a part of the
MCU and Hugh Jackman is returning
donning the classic yellow suit and so
far based off of everything we know and
all the rumors that are going around
this movie is set to be amazing but let
us know what you think about the yellow
suit in the comments down below do you
like it do you not like it is it
everything you hope for or is it a
little bit cheesy please let us know all
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all of the latest
Deadpool and MCU news and leave a
comment down below so you can enter our
giveaway you can also further support
the channel by checking us out on
patreon checking out our website and
joining our Discord server and you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf